thebestplacetodiscusspoliticsandthenewswithotherdavidpakmanshowviewersandlistenersisthedavidpakmanshowsubredditatdavidpakman.com
slash Reddit just shy of 16,000 of our viewers
and listeners regularly discussing politics
there.
A few interesting posts I noticed this morning.
One says, can we stop saying Trumpists is
Trump supporters?
This is the Republican party carrying on from
10 years ago.
Yeah, this is a really important thing.
I do believe there is relevance to talking
about a Trumpist in that it is someone who
actively supports Trump because there are
conservatives, libertarians, uh, evangelical
right-wingers who don't support Trump.
It's not most of them though.
So I do think there is relevance to talking
about Trumpists but, and the point here is
that the tea party was a sort of precursor
to Trumpists.
I think that we've made very clear over the
last several weeks and months that getting
rid of Trump doesn't fix the Republican party
because the Republican party being broken
is what allowed Trump to win a primary to
begin with.
And ultimately to win losing, of course in
the popular vote by a record, million number
of votes, but winning the electoral college,
that was all enabled by the Republican party
and even after Trump has gone, that is still
something they're going to have to contend
with.
Another post from the subreddit, David's stance
on Buddha, judge.
Hey everyone.
I took a break from Pacman's show awhile back
because at the time the new cycle as well
as what David was reporting was kind of the
same old, same old.
I've been a booted judge supporter since the
start.
And I was wondering why does it appear David
doesn't report on Buddha judge much?
Uh, yeah.
Listen, we talk about booted judge.
We've booted judge.
We talk about him in proportion to how much
he warrants or deserves being talked about.
I find him on a personal level to feel a little
bit phony and extraordinarily scripted.
So that's my personal take on his PR, uh,
appearance.
He really had no shot for awhile.
He now has picked up up to 8% support and
importantly he's doing very well in the two
first primaries, Iowa and New Hampshire.
So we talked about Buddha, judge Moore during
the debate livestream this week we're talking
about Buddha judge more in the context of
those early primaries.
I'm doing my best to talk about candidates
in proportion to how important I believe their
presence is within the primary and whether
I have anything to say about them.
And that's basically it.
A lot of people shocked about my, uh, coming
clean about my health insurance plan earlier
this week and a lot of shocked posts about
it, including this one from black green who
says is David Pacman's health insurance common?
I've been in the military 15 years, but under,
before that, under my parents' insurance for
me, my wife and daughter healthcare is almost
free.
Uh, anyways, David's situation, common $400
a month in premiums, a $2,000 deductible and
copays, that's just a straight up scam.
Sadly in the private market it is.
Some people have plans that terrible, uh,
through employers.
Uh, I am lucky enough to have that plan merely
by paying for it myself.
Since I am self-employed.
Yes, the system is broken.
Join the discussion@davidpakman.com slash
Reddit